c'est parti c'est quatre applications
donc tu pourrais pas te passer sur ton
téléphone instagram facebook webster et
fait sa pub
et ça
passe il avec les mots il ne boit pas il
ne boit pas attention c'est parti
attention
[Rires]
bien sûr le roi ne reviendrait pas
vous connaissez un bien entendu fait pas
dans la peur voici trois choses que tu
es fier d'exhiber sexe mes fesses et mes
seins
elle n'est pas créée ni pour le sexy
voir
la culture enfin des américains mais
c'est vrai exhiber sa culture nora oui
pour un petit peu
patio où la chine s'est pas vu ce qui
avait marqué e mail fit
sentir m3 raison de te mettre à genoux
d'autant qu'hier mariage pour amasser
quelque chose par terre et pour eux
[Rires]
c'est toujours pareil dhabi j'ai eu peur
qu'elle reverra y aller elle a dit tu as
bien dans le four ways actuellement la
septième semaine dernière oui mais pour
nous c'était déjà guère
attention
mais là il complète de trois façons je
ne pourrais pas de survivre sans sans
aveu et sans manger et sans boire
non moi s'ils n'ont pas la
taille est passé d' harry ça tu vas
adorer attention questions urgentes ont
tous trouvent t3 surnom si tu étais une
star du heat
la saucisse de strasbourg
fibres de boulbi et guillaume la tob
[Applaudissements]
gibrat de boulbi
sava delphine ça vous donne envie mais
c'est très bien
résumons très bien à bazzo attention est
parti à
cyril féraud cite trois trucs
insupportable chez les personnes âgées
la mauvaise haleine les dents qui
tombent et les cheveux violets
[Rires]
j'ai deux boîtes
[Applaudissements]
il a perdu la fonction publique
[Rires]
je rappelle que bernard montiel ont fait
partie
isabelle morini bosc à jean trois trucs
à faire cantons partenaires ont flou
comme un cochon le réveil est juste et
de l'eau ou le faire l'amour sans qu'il
le sache
sans qu'il le sache
ah bon
merci en tout cas merci attention
il chercha non non non non c'est pas
moi si trois moments il ne faut pas
vraiment avoir une érection alors aux
toilettes
pourquoi
oui quand on danse et quand on écrit
lundi
je repose la même question à maxime
gainey au fola la beauté un exil mamani
sa mère de son père dans son frère aux
normes
tu avais pensé à ça parce qu'il disait
si j'avais un marteau
[Rires]
attention attention
rayonner sur m6 trois maisons
embarrassante de consulter un docteur à
l'ask ohmynews
la sonatt coincer
je te dirai après la galère et parce que
parce qu'on a un truc coincé aussi quoi
vi vous savez que aux urgences il ya des
ya des gens qui sont coincés des choses
très gênante oui quoi ça dans l'arrière
train
alors et alors ce type est celle ci
c'est quand jimmy colas et ça c'est
arrivé à plein de femmes déjà quand on
m'a cherché des colloques parce qu'un
s'abattit fait coincer ça arrive aussi
ouais
mais au fond une porte qui médecin
effectivement est quelqu'un qui s'était
fait coincer enfin une bouteille de vin
qui a explosé
il a fait plus qu'un tunnel il ya
peut-être une cave à vin oui cette année
autre chose aussi il ya quelqu'un qui
essayait d'un service et un rat nom
des souris vivantes à l'intérieur et
entre temps ça s'est très très mal
placée voilà une boule de pétanque voilà
c'est bon
chantier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et 2,70 à la nuit tu me comprendre mais
je me dis si pour toucher les deux
cochons
[Rires]
les cônes de chantier ça existe vraiment
parce que j'ai une fois fait une
émission mais comment tu
vois si c'est vrai et en fait donc on
voyait les différents articles et au
bout d'un moment j'ai vu des cônes de
signalisation et donc leur ai demandé
mais vous êtes en travaux et il m'a dit
non non c'est un article parmi tant de
merveilleux et le triangle à 50 mètres
[Applaudissements]
il le met comme hadj amadou sall à
risque d'éboulement
attention bernard montiel ont valu trois
raisons pour lesquelles on doit cette
odeur là parce que je l'aimé dans le
fion
et les mii dans le reste de ma voisine
est dans le trou de et dans le nez de
quoi
le dernier ep mélenchon
à l'aller s'il vous plaît en tout cas
c'est vraiment très bien c'est élégant
attention
une coupe à la boiboite rouve 3 excuses
publiques pour ne pas faire l'amour
j'ai mal à la tête
on l'a déjà fait guère et
je dois travailler dans ces nuls dont on
n'est pas déçu alors
je pose la même question il
lui a tranché sur tout le monde
cormier de kevin
g finir
à dix voilà qui ne me plaît plus non en
forme
et le chrono pourquoi tu penses pas quoi
[Rires]
ça va vous sinon
très chaud comme géraldine bois
d'elle-même
la troisième réponse temps mais rien
dans ce choix l attention c'est parti
attention
non non enfin dans sa non attention si
trois raisons de devenir médecin autre
que l'argent syrie parce que les gentils
à trois raisons ouais pour voir des gens
à poil pour
pour dans votre cas l'argent tu as dit
que
c'était dû à laquelle celui que premier
guérir des gens c'était pas mieux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on
fait bien rire des gens ça ne l'est pas
du tout bio les gens voulaient voir des
gens à poil hors
site attention attention
question pour guillaume genton donne
trois raisons de ne pas mettre la vidéo
quand tu appelles ta chérie parce que je
suis chaud parce que je suis avec une
autre 9 et parce que je suis sur le
chemin pour aller voir une hausse notre
attention valérie bénaïm ouf 3 mais
trouve trois façon subtile de faire
comprendre à quelqu'un qu'il pue de la
gueule proches wynn holmes doit pas
manger aujourd'hui
chez le dentiste
[Applaudissements]
attention
gilbert bel 6 3 personnes qui seront
chauve avant toi alors montiel non on
tienne
un perdant
[Musique]
n'importe quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
un
truc fort hills et transforme en
frankenstein
m'a dit non ça va pas bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la chine est en pleine forme et gerani
bit parce que mj berlin va bien
attention
delphine wespiser we done 3 façon de te
remettre d'une rupture à bas en allant
avec quelqu'un d'autre en me mettant
avec une femme en mettant des mines tous
les soirs
à la vie on râle on a vécu pas mal à
regarder isabel coixet ouais non mais
sans lui un truc hein c'est un truc de
ouf ça va vraiment faire et c'est bien
mais je vous dis oh [ __ ] je je je je
veux être la norme
morale est humide au gérant et merci à
l'armée je vais te tuer je leur donne
oui volontiers tu veux quelque chose tu
me fais pas il ya peut-être un truc qui
s'y attachent un truc à grignoter un
brin alors ça c'est mon perso à me faire
du bien l'autre beau gosse ça fait
vraiment attention
benjamin castaldi quels sont les trois
premières choses que tu ferais si je
n'avais plus que 24 heures à vivre
jeffrey l'amour
[Musique]
est nul
guillaume genton elles sont les trois
premières choses que tu ferais tu
n'avais plus que 24 à 10 alors je
donnerai tout mon argent des
associations je lirai plein de livres et
jerrycans tout ce qui bouge et j'irai à
l'atromitos je pose la même question à
isabelle morini-bosc parce que c'est
la première chose que tu ferais tu n'es
plus que malgré ce mardi alors je passe
une soirée avec vous parce que vous êtes
obligé de me l'accordé façon soirée une
deuxième soirée pique - une troisième
soirée
manuel attention je suis
merci attention aux questions mal et les
ménages oui raison de s'inscrire sur
steam d'heure alors que tu es en couple
il m'a trompée donc je vais me venger il
m'a trompée donc je vais me venger après
quoi les allées du bois pour géraldine
maillet il m'a trompée dans ce permis de
jordi de nouveautés et j'ai envie d'un
plan à 4
[Applaudissements]
il va s'en passer dans le restaurant
italien jeu et ça fait cher des bonnes
soeurs c'est sûr attention chastel dit
encore non
6-3 pop que tu ne présenterait jamais à
passeur ou à ta fille
amateur 3 tout
pareil sans rigoler aventure dit la même
chose valérie bénaïm c'est trois potes
que tu nous as en toi ta fille ou à ta
soeur benjamin vous et vous
mesdames bois
moi
j'ai raté ma vie je prends dans mes
questions oui si tu crois pas que tu ne
présentait pas pu avoir d'enfants et
quatre
maires
j'ai vraiment des bâtards attention
delphine donne 4 insultes qui commence
par la lettre c ces connards
qu'aucun godasses couilles molles et ses
moyennes à trois ans a fait carrière
dans du bois
tu vois attention et un maxi la même
question qu connard couilles molles et
cataplasme non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'était génial de gagner gagner